so the modern dating scene is what  happens when every beggar becomes a  Chooser everyone is lonely and desperate  for companionship but the field is so  flooded with options there's such a  surplus that you begin to feel like kind  of like I feel when I'm in the condiment  aisle at Walmart trying to buy mustard  and there are 197 different types of  mustard the overwhelming array of  options paralyzes me and I'm just  standing there slack job questioning  whether I should be settling for just  regular mustard when I could be getting  Gourmet Dijon whole grain honey French  yellow spicy brown white yellow German  mustard instead all of Modern Life is  plagued by this problem everything is  plentiful and can be obtained  effortlessly and cheaply but it's too  plentiful and too effortless and too  cheap